the pleasure to welcome
of our students here for the ZL family
weekend on all of you whatever your
occasion for visiting we have a number
of old friends visiting I saw Stefan and
I see yang and showers back and that's
good to see feel our community coming
back together to the parents I want to
say thank you for loaning us your
children for these years I hope it's a
good experience for them and I know it
will be for us as I say each year in
clarification for the parents when
you're leaving the church today and
you're shaking my hand the fact that I
do not recognize your child or know
their name has absolutely nothing to do
with their pattern of attendance at
church it is clearly the fault of my
aging brain alone every year I have to
say we seem to be cursed with the worst
possible scripture texts for parents we
get I think this is by far the worst
we've had though last year i believe we
had Jesus saying whoever comes to me and
does not hate their mother and their
father cannot be my disciple this year
is not much better we come to patel
chapel in hopes of a word of gentle
inspiration of unity and hope and what
do we get all four of our scriptures or
about how the rich are going to help a
little light reading for sunday from 1st
timothy we get the well-worn maxim for
the love of money is the root of all
kinds of evil as ron read from the
Prophet Amos we get the warning to those
who are comfortable on there I be
couches who feel secure who enjoy the
good life that they will be the first in
Israel to be exiled even the psalmist
who we can usually trust to be kind to
us on rough lectionary days reminds us
that our hope and happiness yes is in
God but that this god is first and
foremost about justice for the oppressed
and food for the hungry and finally this
brutal story Ted read from Luke's Gospel
if you know it you know how tough it is
with the rich man
the one who feasted sumptuously in
purple robes now roasting in Hades while
the poor man ignored by the rich man
though he was dumped on the rich man
steps every day is now in heaven sitting
on father Abraham's lap and not only
that the justice of this reversal of
fortunes isn't even open for discussion
father Abraham says sorry that's the way
it is the rich man had a good in this
life and so now is in agony and the poor
man suffered evil and so is comforted
this is the good news of the gospel
especially at Yale these are sort of
hard words to hear we are a very very
privileged community and I don't know if
your upbringing was anything like mine
but polite people don't talk about money
my mother always said talking about
money was goes and was not for polite
conversation here we have very many rich
people in our community and also very
many poor people so talking about money
risks high emotion and sometimes
defensiveness talking about money makes
everyone uncomfortable everyone worries
that they're judged because they have
too much or too little and so we just
don't talk about it except in the most
clinical and distant economic terms but
sadly the Bible this Sunday won't let us
alone well there's no easy way to
spiritualize this message the prophets
keep poking at everything we want to
keep secret the prophets keep sticking a
fork into that point that we most want
to hide I think the reality is that our
idea of money in this society is as
twisted as it was for the rich man a few
generations back it seems like faith was
our foundation our source and money was
a necessary evil to be carefully kept in
its place but today i would suggest
money and security are now
are unquestioned religion while
Christianity today I think is seen as a
potentially dangerous option to be
carefully fenced in and not allowed to
affect too much of what's really
important to life I talked to a lot of
students here as you would imagine who
have big questions about Christianity
and many of whom are very skeptical and
they say to me how could you accept such
a dogmatic faith that flies in the face
of science and reason and demand such
utter devotion and I think to myself
which faith are we talking about is it
God or is it money a few generations ago
I think religion was just assumed all
right-thinking people believed it and
only a few odd characters questioned it
but today I think a certain kind of
free-market economics is our
unquestioned Dogma unquestioned and
unquestionable even if it flies in the
face of our historical experience
especially the last five years I think
money is taking over more and more of
our lives and it demands complete
devotion and blind faith and we give it
excuse me our scripture writers weren't
critical of wealth because they were
socialists are anarchists they were not
communists wealth they said could be a
blessing from God but instead they saw
in their own times that the love of
money caused bad things to happen caused
inequality and suffering and corruption
love of money cause people to forget
their covenant responsibilities to their
neighbors love of money perverted
religion in the state and even business
sounds strangely familiar and it would
be wonderful have this applied only to
the one percent at the top or the one
tenth of one percent or the one
hundredth of one percent but those folks
couldn't get away with it they couldn't
get away with what they get away with if
we didn't buy into the same dog mother
put them where they are I don't know
about you but I think about money I
think about the future and I
hurry I worry about retirement savings
and home repairs and all sorts of silly
things and I spent a lot of time
thinking about it and what struck me as
I was writing the sermon I was I was
thinking about that rich man and that
poor man is that God never comes into
that conversation in my head money is in
its own little territory over here and
it has nothing to do with God it is its
own God I think we've been persuaded
that economics is real and God as a
pleasant fantasy we've been convinced
that it's impolite to say that love of
wealth could be immoral or even unholy
this summer I was on vacation and I
heard professor michael sandel who
teaches at some College in Cambridge
Massachusetts I've never heard of it and
he argued that the free market
revolution of the last 35 years means
that now everything is available for a
price never thought about this way but
he gave examples he said in Santa Ana
California you can upgrade your jail
cell for 82 dollars a night he said you
can now pay a woman in india six
thousand two hundred and fifty dollars
to carry our child as a surrogate mother
you can pay ten thousand dollars for
designer eggs and sperm to guarantee a
perfect child and most scarce of all you
can pay fifteen hundred dollars a year
and get your doctor's cell phone number
lobbyists in washington are paying
homeless people fifteen to twenty
dollars an hour to hold places in line
for them at important hearings send out
questions whether it's right for markets
to run more and more of our lives for
there to be for-profit schools and
hospitals and prisons and police and now
even a for-profit military and is
grounds for questioning are not
themselves religious but they sound just
like Amos and Timothy in a society where
everything up is up for sale inequality
grows and the poor suffer more deeply
then send l has this passage he says if
the only advantage of affluence was the
ability to buy yachts or sports cars or
fancy vacations
inequality wouldn't matter much but as
money comes to buy more and more
political influence good medical care a
home in a safe neighborhood access to
elite schools the distribution of income
and wealth looms larger and larger and
we're all good things are bought and
sold having lots of money makes all the
difference in the world it can separate
life and death sindel also argues that
putting every public good up for sale
corrupts these goods I never thought of
it this way he says markets not only
allocate goods neutrally but they
express and promote certain values and
that perhaps some things should not be
put up for sale education he said health
perhaps there are things that shouldn't
be for sale historically we've decided
that people should not be put up for
sale we called that slavery children
should not be bought or sold you should
be able to pay someone to do your jury
duty for you it's a funny thing that we
draw the line there that you can't sell
your vote on eBay we do draw lines I
think we're getting perilously close to
breaking these ancient rules without
even realizing it I think we've handed
over our society to the religion of
money to the free market which proudly
says it is a moral in st. Luke story
about the rich man and Lazarus the rich
man's problem was not his money it was
that he never saw Lazarus lying at his
doorstep Lazarus was there every day
begging for crumbs but the rich man was
surrounded by high walls and many
servants whose job it was to be sure
that he never saw anything unpleasant
well doesn't have to insulate us from
the suffering of the world but most
often it does as John Stendahl has
written the chasm between Hades and
Abraham's abode is wide and unbridgeable
in the scripture but no wider or more
unbridgeable than the chasm between the
rich
man's feasting room and Lazarus laying
in his steps and we are living in a
world where the chasm between rich and
poor is becoming just as wide and just
as unbridgeable more than ever the rich
are getting richer and the poor are
locked into poverty without hope and my
message today from our scripture is that
God cares about this I read on Friday
about Robert benmashi chairman of AIG
one of the Corporations responsible for
the 2008 financial collapse who recently
compared public opposition to high
executive bonuses to lynchings in the
Jim Crow South really it would be easy
to hate the rich but then I think that
compared to most of the world I'm the
rich be easy to blame the rich for
everything but the problem I think is
much bigger than that it isn't just a
few folks we've taken God and morality
out of the world and replaced them with
an amoral mechanism and unquestioning
faith that the free flow of capital is a
natural law and supersedes God's law
sandell writes markets don't pass
judgments they don't have morality if
someone is willing to pay for sex or a
kidney and a consenting adult is willing
to sell the only question the market
asks is how much but we do come to
church for good news not bad news right
and there is good news today God is
bigger than the Federal Reserve the IMF
the New York Stock Exchange and the
fortune 500 and God's prophets want to
tell us that we don't have to live in
this kind of society we're enthralled by
markets and money under a kind of spell
that says justice and morality really
don't exist and even if they did there'd
be no way to enforce them but our
scriptures break the spell they remind
us that our communities are bound by a
covenant to care for the poor in the
suffering too
recognized injustice and corruption
around us and to believe that God and
God's people have the power to change
anything even our economic system I
wonder what would happen if instead of
presuming that we have to start with
this system what if we were to presume
to start with God's kingdom where
justice rolls down like waters and
righteousness like an ever-flowing
stream if that kingdom were our starting
point and we just worked out the details
from there Jesus had a lot to say about
wealth and poverty as he as does the
whole Bible but most of all Jesus
himself wanted to bridge the chasm that
isolates the poor and gives give a new
vision where dishonest tax collectors
would volunteer to give back their money
that's one Bible story where rich young
ruler give all they have to the poor
where God reaches out to the poor and
demands of the church and the state do
justice for them Jesus he's the poor not
as a social problem to be solved but as
individuals beloved by God each with a
story each with a heart each sought by
God like the Shepherd for the lost sheep
what we're going to do here today in
this church I think opens a door will
come to this table in a few moments
where everyone eats the same bread and
drinks the same wine where there is no
first class or there is no platinum
reward level and after worship will make
sandwiches not fancy sandwiches just
plain sandwiches ham and turkey and
peanut butter and jelly and we'll go out
on the green after church and we'll do
our best to treat every person we meet
there as an honored guest on this day I
want to think about the possibility that
money is just a tool money is just
something we can use for good ends or
bad ends and that we are not locked into
a system
from which we cannot escape that there
is such a thing as holiness and
righteousness and morality and our use
of money and I don't want to claim I've
got it because I know I don't you don't
want to look at my credit card bill I
spend money on really stupid things a
lot of it I spent five hundred dollars
on a pair of shoes over summer vacation
and I love those shoes
but I think there is a way for us to
reclaim our lives from this system that
entraps us and the system that makes us
unhappy and uncomfortable because we see
the state of the world we're in and we
want to break free and the gospel shows
us the way shows us a different way a
different vision so I want to thank you
parents and families for sending your
children here they are remarkable they
are super smart they are hopeful and
they are motivated and I think the final
good news this Sunday is that even with
this word from these scary texts the
good news is that we are passing along
to these students a prophetic vision
where justice and equality and hope our
god-given and God guaranteed for all
people the good news is that they will
see the world differently and they will
challenge what we presumed was the only
way to run the world and they will show
us new paths to God's kingdom oh man